(man) TONIGHT,
HOPEFUL ENTREPRENEURS
WHO BELIEVE THEY HAVE
THE NEXT BIG BUSINESS IDEA
WILL ENTER THE SHARK TANK
SEEKING THE FINANCIAL BACKING
TO MAKE THEIR DREAMS
COME TRUE.
THE NAME
OF OUR BUSINESS IS...
(both) ♪ MR. PONCHO ♪
♪ OH ♪
(laughs)
THE SHARKS
ARE READY TO INVEST
USING THEIR OWN MONEY,
BUT ONLY FOR THE RIGHT PERSON
WITH THE RIGHT IDEA.
WHAT ARE YOU OFFERING ME?
WELL, LET'S PULL OUT
A CALCULATOR AND FIND OUT.
HE GOT A CALCULATOR.
HE GOT A CALCULATOR ON HIM.
BUT FIRST, THE ENTREPRENEURS
MUST CONVINCE A SHARK
TO INVEST THE FULL AMOUNT
THEY'RE ASKING FOR
OR THEY'LL WALK AWAY
WITH NOTHING.
GREED IS GOOD, BUT WE NEED
TO BE GREEDY TOGETHER.
AND IF THE SHARKS HEAR
A GOOD IDEA,
THEY'LL FIGHT EACH OTHER
FOR A PIECE OF IT.
I'LL GIVE YOU $200,000
FOR 20%.
$300,000 FOR 35%.
IT'S A BIG MISTAKE
TO (bleep) ME ON THIS ONE.
(man) ♪ THE BEST THINGS
IN LIFE ARE FREE ♪
♪ BUT THAT AIN'T REALLY
GOOD ENOUGH FOR ME ♪
♪ I NEED MONEY ♪
♪ THAT'S WHAT I WANT ♪
♪ WHAT I WANT ♪
(man) FIRST IN IS JEFF WOLSKY,
WHO'S COME TO THE SHARK TANK
SEEKING AN INVESTMENT
FOR AN EXTENSION OF
AN ALREADY LUCRATIVE BUSINESS.
♪♪
HI, MY NAME IS JEFF WOLSKY,
AND I'M HERE TO INTRODUCE
THE BOBBLE PLACE
AND ASK FOR $75,000
IN EXCHANGE FOR 18% EQUITY
WITHIN MY BUSINESS.
(Robert laughing)
AS YOU CAN SEE, WE MAKE
CUSTOM BOBBLEHEAD DOLLS.
(sharks laugh)
(Barbara) THEY'RE FREAKY. MAN.
HERE YOU GO. ONE FOR YOU.
(Jeff) AND ONE FOR YOU.
(sharks laugh)
(Robert) I LIKE IT.
(Daymond)
I'M DEFINITELY CUTE, BUT...
(O'Leary) THAT IS
A GOOD‐LOOKING BOBBLE DOLL.
(Barbara laughs)
LISTEN, JEFF,
SO FAR, GOOD SUCKING UP.
THANK YOU.
CLIENTS CAN PROVIDE
A PHOTOGRAPH TO US.
WE WILL HAND SCULPT THE DOLL
TO RESEMBLE IT.
THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS,
THEY CAN ACTUALLY
SEE THE DOLL AS IT'S BEING MADE.
WE'LL PROVIDE PHOTO PROOFS
OF THE SCULPTED HEAD.
THEY GET TO APPROVE IT
OR EVEN MAKE CHANGES IF NEEDED.
IT'S EXCITING
AND IT'S FUN FOR THE CLIENTS.
WHAT I'M LOOKING TO DO
WITH THE‐‐WITH THE MONEY
THAT I'M ASKING FOR
IS TO BRING THESE TO PHYSICAL
LOCATIONS WITHIN SHOPPING MALLS,
AMUSEMENT PARKS,
EVEN NATIONAL CHAIN STORES.
SO YOU WANT A RETAIL LOCATION
THAT SELLS BOBBLEHEAD DOLLS?
IT'S LIKE A KIOSK LOCATION
WHERE THE CLIENT
CAN ACTUALLY WALK IN.
THEY CAN SELECT FROM OVER
100 DIFFERENT BODY STYLES
THAT WE OFFER‐‐
HERE'S JUST A FEW.
THEN THEY CAN SUPPLY
A PHOTOGRAPH TO US
OR WE CAN TAKE THEIR PHOTO.
AND THEN THAT'S WHEN
THAT PROCESS BEINGS.
IS THIS AN EXISTING BUSINESS,
JEFF?
UH, IT IS A COMPANY
THAT WE CURRENTLY HAVE AS WELL,
IT'S A SEPARATE COMPANY. IT'S
AN ONLINE BUSINESS CURRENTLY.
AND IS THAT BUSINESS
GENERATING REVENUE?
YES, IT IS.
HOW MUCH IS THAT?
UH, REVENUES, IN A YEARLY
FASHION, OF SEVEN FIGURES.
BUT WAIT A MINUTE. WHY ARE‐‐WHY
ARE WE NOT INVESTING IN THAT?
WAIT, WAIT, WAIT, WAIT, WAIT.
LET'S‐‐LET'S GET RIGHT TO THIS.
HOW LONG HAS THE BUSINESS
BEEN OUT?
FIVE YEARS.
THIS IS GONNA BE ANOTHER
DIVISION OF THAT BUSINESS?
IT'S GONNA BE A SEPARATE
DIVISION OF THAT BUSINESS.
AND YOU WANT US
TO INVEST $75,000
FOR 18% OF THIS NEW BUSINESS?
THAT'S CORRECT.
WHY WOULD I INVEST
IN A BUSINESS OF VAPOR
WHEN I CAN GET A PIECE
OF A REAL COMPANY?
WELL, AT THIS POINT, WE ARE
OFFERING JUST THE BOBBLE PLACE.
IT'S A SEPARATE ENTITY.
YOU MEAN THE VAPOR BUSINESS.
IF YOU HAVE A REAL BUSINESS, WHY
ARE YOU KEEPING THAT FROM US?
OH, IT'S NOT KEEPING.
IT'S A SEPARATE DIVISION.
TELL US THE SALES.
IT‐‐IT'S A 7‐DIGIT BUSINESS.
BUT WHAT'S THE NUMBER?
(Barbara) WHAT IS IT?
(Daymond) WHAT SEVEN DIGITS?
WHAT'S THE NUMBER? IS IT
$1 MILLION? IS IT $10 MILLION?
IT'S OVER $1 MILLION A YEAR.
YEAH, BABY!
THAT'S WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT.
ALL RIGHT! THERE WE GO.
(Daymond) AND HOW MUCH OF THAT
ARE WE GETTING?
WELL, AGAIN, I'M OFFERING
A SEPARATE DIVISION WHICH WILL
THEN UTILIZE THE FACTORY
IN WHICH WE CURRENTLY RUN
TO CREATE THESE DOLLS.
SO I GET TO HAVE THE HIGHER‐RISK
LOCATION, BRICK‐AND‐MORTAR IDEA,
AND YOU KEEP THE SUCCULENT,
HIGH‐MARGIN ONLINE BUSINESS.
WHY DON'T YOU
GIVE HIM A CHANCE TO TALK
ABOUT THE OTHER BUSINESS?
WHAT'S THE KIOSK GONNA COST?
HOW MUCH MONEY CAN YOU MAKE?
WHAT'S THE TRAFFIC ON A KIOSK?
(O'Leary) WAIT A SECOND.
WAIT A SECOND.
DON'T. GIVE HIM A CHANCE.
LET'S HEAR ABOUT
THE OTHER SIDE BEFORE YOU...
I'D LIKE HIM TO START
BY SAYING AND APOLOGIZING
FOR BEING SO GREEDY.
WELL, IT'S NOT REALLY GREEDY.
(O'Leary) YES,
IT'S VERY GREEDY.
IT'S NOT GREEDY
BECAUSE WHAT I'M DOING IS,
I'M GIVING THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
YOU TO MAKE SUBSTANTIAL MONEY
KNOWING THAT AN ONLINE BUSINESS
IS MAKING SEVEN FIGURES.
THE PRODUCT HAS BEEN PROVEN
IN SEPARATE SALES DIVISIONS.
BUT YOU'RE NOT GIVING ME
ANY OF THE EXISTING PRODUCT.
YOU'RE ASKING ME
TO TAKE ALL THE RISK
AND GIVING ME
NONE OF THE BENEFIT.
HOW CAN YOU DO THAT?
YOU'RE ON A VERY, VERY SLIPPERY
SLOPE AT THIS MOMENT WITH US.
I WOULD LIKE YOU TO RETHINK
WHAT YOU'RE GONNA OFFER US
IN THE EXISTING BUSINESS.
BECAUSE WHY HAVE ME
IN A PARTNER‐‐IN SOMETHING I
DON'T KNOW WHAT IS GONNA WORK?
BUT, DAYMOND,
HE'S NOT OFFERING YOU
ANY OF THE EXISTING BUSINESS.
(Daymond) WELL, I WANT HIM
TO RETHINK THAT.
ARE YOU WILLING TO GIVE US
SOME INSURANCE ON OUR MONEY
WITH YOUR EXISTING BUSINESS?
IT WOULD REALLY DEPEND
ON WHAT KIND OF INSURANCE
YOU'RE LOOKING FOR.
I WOULD BE MORE COMFORTABLE
GIVING A LARGER PERCENTAGE
ON THIS "VAPOR BUSINESS"‐‐
WHICH IS TRULY A BUSINESS‐‐
AND A SMALLER PERCENTAGE
POSSIBLY
ON THE MORE GUARANTEED
BUSINESS.
JEFF, PLEASE,
TELL US ABOUT THE KIOSKS.
GIVE US SOME NUMBERS.
GENERALLY, YOU CAN RENT
A KIOSK FROM A MALL.
(Barbara) MM‐HMM.
USUALLY IT'S A $1,500 FEE
PER MONTH.
OR SEASONALLY
IT COULD BE UP TO $3,000.
THAT'S SUBSTANTIAL.
WHAT WOULD AN AVERAGE KIOSK
GENERATE IN SALES
IN A TYPICAL MALL?
WELL, YOU KNOW,
THAT'S REALLY HARD TO SAY.
SO IF YOU CAN'T
BREAK OUT THAT DATA,
WHY DO YOU THINK THAT THIS IS
A GOOD OPPORTUNITY?
WELL, I THINK‐‐I THINK THAT
WE'RE MISSING A BIG AUDIENCE.
MANY PEOPLE DO NOT KNOW
THAT A SINGLE DOLL
CAN BE MADE TO LOOK LIKE THEM
FOR LESS THAN $100.
WHAT'S THE PROFIT
IN YOUR EXISTING BUSINESS?
BETWEEN $500,000 AND $600,000
PROFIT PER YEAR.
(Robert) OKAY, SO‐‐
YEAH! WHAT ARE YOU EVEN THINKING
ABOUT GOING INTO A MALL FOR?
BECAUSE I THINK WE'RE MISSING‐‐
SEE, WHAT YOU'RE NOT HEARING‐‐
WE'RE MISSING THE PEOPLE
THAT DO NOT KNOW THIS EXISTS.
IT DOESN'T MATTER!
YOU'VE GOT A BUSINESS THAT'S
MAKING A PHENOMENAL PROFIT.
I UNDERSTAND, BUT IT NEEDS‐‐
I FORBID YOU TO EVER EVEN THINK
ABOUT GOING INTO A MALL.
BUT LIKE ANY BUSINESS,
YOU NEED TO TAKE THAT NEXT STEP.
YOU NEED TO, LIKE‐‐
I HAVE TO PUT YOUR MONEY
IN PROTECTIVE CUSTODY FROM YOU.
I'LL GIVE $75,000 FOR 18%
OF THE EXISTING BUSINESS,
AND YOU ARE FORBIDDEN
TO EVER GO INTO MALLS, EVER.
AND YOU ARE GOING TO GROW
THE ONLINE BUSINESS...
HMM.
AND FORGET THIS CRAZY IDEA.
I DON'T NEED $75,000
FOR THE ONLINE BUSINESS.
WAIT A MINUTE.
ARE YOU TAKING MY DEAL OR NOT?
I WOULD NOT TAKE THAT DEAL.
WHY NOT?
BECAUSE I DON'T NEED THE MONEY
FOR MY ONLINE BUSINESS.
SO WHAT ARE YOU HERE FOR?
I'M HERE TO EXPAND AND BRING
THE PRODUCTS TO CONSUMERS‐‐
NO, YOU'RE HERE
TO PUT MY MONEY IN HARM'S WAY
WHEN I COULD PUT IT SAFELY
IN YOUR BUSINESS
WITH THE LITTLE HEADS THAT WORK,
NOT THE VAPOR HEADS.
ARE YOU COUNTERING MY OFFER?
I WOULD DECLINE THAT DEAL.
HERE'S WHAT UNCLE KEVIN
BOBBLEHEAD IS SAYING.
UNCLE KEVIN WANTS TO PUT
A SPECIAL BRACELET
ON YOUR ANKLE.
EVERY TIME YOU MENTION "MALL"‐‐
200 VOLTS. WHAMMO.
EVERY TIME YOU MENTION
THE WORD "KIOSK"...
WELL, WAIT, LET ME‐‐
LET ME SPEAK.
YOU GET A SHOCK.
BUT‐‐BUT LET ME‐‐
IT KEEPS GOING UP HIGHER
EVERY TIME YOU MENTION IT.
OKAY, BECAUSE I'M
A WONDERFUL GUY,
I AM WILLING TO DO
75K FOR 15%.
YEAH, SEE, THAT‐‐AGAIN‐‐
AND YOU'RE STILL FORBIDDEN
TO EVER MENTION
THE IDEA OF A MALL.
LET ME THROW THIS AT YOU,
IF I MAY.
WHAT VALUE DO I HAVE TO TAKE
$75,000 ON AN EXISTING BUSINESS
THAT DOESN'T NEED $75,000?
YOU'RE SITTING ON MY CARPET
ASKING FOR MONEY,
AND I'M TELLING YOU
HOW I'D GIVE IT TO YOU.
JEFF, YOU'RE ASKING FOR $75,000
FOR AN UNTESTED BUSINESS.
WELL, LET ME ASK YOU THIS.
WOULD YOU CONSIDER TAKING
THE 18% OF THIS VAPOR COMPANY,
AND THEN IF I GAVE YOU
MAYBE 5%
OF THE EXISTING BUSINESS,
WOULD YOU CONSIDER THAT?
(Daymond) NOW, JEFF‐‐
OHH! I WANNA BUY THIS COMPANY
AND WHACK THIS GUY!
JEFF, I JUST WANNA TELL YOU
WHERE I STAND.
I LIKE THE IDEA,
BUT NOT THE KIOSK IDEA.
GREED IS GOOD,
BUT WE NEED
TO BE GREEDY TOGETHER.
AND VERY FEW PEOPLE HAVE EVER
WALKED UP TO ME AND TOLD ME
THAT THEY WERE GONNA USE
MY MONEY FOR JUST THEIR BENEFIT
AND NOT OUR BENEFIT.
BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY,
THE KIOSK IS A SALES ASPECT
FOR YOUR EXISTING BUSINESS.
(Barbara) BUT‐‐
SO WITH THAT...
I AM OUT.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS,
THE AMOUNT OF MONEY
YOU'RE ASKING FOR TO TEST
SOMETHING IS WAY OVERBOARD.
YOU'RE ASKING FOR $75,000.
FOR 10 GRAND,
YOU COULD'VE TESTED IT.
I'M OUT.
JEFF, I CAN'T SHAKE
THE FEELING I GOT
WHEN I FOUND OUT, BY SURPRISE,
"OH, THE OTHER BUSINESS
ISN'T INCLUDED."
I FELT A LITTLE TRICKED.
AND I THINK THAT'S A TERRIBLE
WAY TO START A RELATIONSHIP.
SO FOR THAT REASON ALONE,
I'M OUT.
JEFF, LET ME GO BACK
TO THE ORIGINAL BUSINESS.
WHAT WAS THE PROFIT AGAIN?
OF THE ORIGINAL?
BETWEEN $500,000 AND $600,000.
WHY DON'T YOU HAVE
AN ACTUAL NUMBER?
WHY IS IT "BETWEEN $500,000
AND $600,000"?
WELL, IT‐‐IT JUST DEPENDS
ON, UM, WHICH YEAR WE WERE IN
WHERE WE WE'RE AT.
WHAT KIND OF AN ACCOUNTANT
DO YOU USE?
'CAUSE MY ACCOUNTANT USUALLY
GIVES ME PRETTY HARD NUMBERS,
DOESN'T GO IN BETWEEN.
UH, AGAIN, I CAME HERE
WITHOUT THE CONCEPT
OF BRINGING THAT IN,
SO I‐‐
YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT
YOUR OWN BUSINESS MAKES PER YEAR
WHEN YOU DO YOUR TAXES?
WELL, OF COURSE I DO.
OKAY, SO WHAT'S THAT NUMBER?
BETWEEN
$500,000 AND $600,000.
(sharks laugh)
OKAY.
ARE YOU IN OR OUT?
WELL, I'M‐‐I'M SOMEWHERE BETWEEN
"I'M OUT" AND "I'M IN." (laughs)
LISTEN, FORGET THIS NOISE.
HOW ABOUT THIS?
I'LL GIVE 100 GRAND
FOR 20% OF YOUR COMPANY.
BUT YOU NEED SOME COACHING
REGARDING MALLS.
YOU GOT A MALL ADDICTION.
YOU GOTTA GET RID OF THAT.
(laughter)
YOU GET A $100,000 CHECK
FROM ME.
I SEND YOU OFF TO BETTY FORD‐‐
THE SPECIAL MALL DIVISION.
YOU GET OVER THAT WHOLE IDEA.
BUT LET ME ASK YOU THIS‐‐
WHAT ELSE DO YOU OFFER, THEN,
BESIDES JUST GIVING ME A CHECK?
WHAT ABOUT EXPERIENCE?
YOU GET ME.
JEFF, HE OFFERS YOU BAD JOKES.
NO, NO, YOU GET ME.
YOU GET ME.
(chuckles)
ALL RIGHT, JEFF,
I'LL GIVE YOU $125,000
FOR 20%.
WELL, POSSIBLY‐‐
POSSIBLY TOGETHER,
WITH MULTIPLE REALMS
OF EXPERTISE,
WE CAN EVEN MAKE THIS
EVEN SWEETER.
SUCH AS?
WE CAN ACCEPT THE $125,000.
WE CAN ACCEPT THE $100,000.
WE CAN GO TO 10% PER PERSON,
MAKING IT 20%.
STILL A GREAT RETURN
ON YOUR MONEY.
YOU'RE SAYING 20%
FOR $200,000?
UH, IT'D BE $225,000.
WAIT A SECOND.
I OFFERED $100,000
FOR 20% OF THE BUSINESS.
I OFFERED $125,000 FOR 20%.
WHAT I WANT YOU TO DO, GO BACK
INTO THE DARK FOR A MINUTE
'CAUSE I HAVE A LITTLE PROBLEM
I'M GONNA TAKE CARE OF.
LOOK, THIS IS NUTS.
WE'RE NEGOTIATING THE PRICE
UP AGAINST EACH OTHER.
SO HERE'S WHAT WE SHOULD DO.
LET'S GO BACK TO MY ORIGINAL
DEAL‐‐$100,000 FOR 20%.
HE DOUBLED THE PRICE
WHEN YOU GOT INVOLVED.
YOU GOTTA CUT HIM BACK.
THAT'S THE DEAL.
♪♪
ROBERT, THE GUY
IS MESSING AROUND WITH US.
BRING HIM BACK.
ALL RIGHT. JEFF.
♪♪
THREE SHARKS ARE OUT.
KEVIN AND ROBERT
HAVE ASKED JEFF TO STEP OUTSIDE
AFTER HEARING JEFF'S
COUNTEROFFER
OF $225,000 FOR A 20% STAKE
IN HIS BUSINESS.
LET'S GO BACK
TO MY ORIGINAL DEAL.
$100,000 FOR 20%.
THAT'S THE DEAL.
BRING HIM BACK.
ALL RIGHT. JEFF.
♪♪
JEFF, HELL IS FREEZING OVER,
AND, UH, KEVIN AND I CAME TO
A MEETING OF THE MINDS.
SO LET'S BE CLEAR
ON WHAT THE OFFER IS.
$100,000...
FOR 20% OF THE BUSINESS.
ROBERT AND I ARE GONNA GO
50/50 ON THAT.
THAT'S ALL YOU'RE GETTING.
YOU TRIED TO MOVE US UP,
BUT NO, NO, NO, NO, NANETTE.
STAYING AT $100,000,
20% OF THE BUSINESS.
THAT'S THE OFFER. YES OR NO?
UNFORTUNATELY,
I WOULD HAVE TO DECLINE.
BUT, JEFF, I'LL GO BACK
TO MY OTHER OFFER.
I'LL GIVE YOU THE $125,000
FOR 20%.
(groans)
BUT LET ME ADR‐‐ARE YOU NOW
OFFICIALLY OUT OF THIS OFFER?
I'M OUT.
UM, I WOULD CONSIDER
THE‐‐THE...
I WOULD CONSIDER $100,000
FOR 7%.
JEFF, I'VE LEARNED,
IN BUSINESS, WHEN SOMETHING
IS THIS COMPLICATED
THE DAY WE GET TOGETHER...
MM‐HMM.
UM, THERE'S AN OLD
YIDDISH SAYING THAT SAYS,
"THE WAY IT BEGINS IS
THE WAY IT ENDS." SO I'M OUT.
JEFF, WE'RE DONE.
♪♪
YOU KNOW WHAT
THE REALITY WAS?
HE WAS NEVER GONNA TAKE
YOUR DEAL.
HE WAS NEVER GONNA TAKE MY DEAL.
HE WASN'T GONNA TAKE ANY DEAL.
THE ONLY REASON THIS GUY CAME
OUT WAS TO TAKE $75,000 FROM US
AND BURN IT
TO TRY A MARKETING IDEA.
HE'S GONE. IT DOESN'T MATTER.
IN HIS PLACE IS A DOLL. BYE.
WHO? WHO WAS HERE?
I FORGET. NEXT.
I DON'T REMEMBER ANY MORE.
YOU KNOW,
THEY CALLED ME GREEDY.
BUT LOOK, THEY'RE TRYING TO
STEAL A PORTION OF MY COMPANY.
THAT'S JUST NOT HAPPENING.
JUST WEEKS AGO,
WE MET ENTREPRENEURS HEATH
AND BRETT FROM PORK BARREL BBQ
AND WATCHED THEM STRIKE A DEAL
WITH BARBARA CORCORAN.
THE OFFER IS, I'LL BE HAPPY
TO GIVE YOU THE $50,000,
BUT FOR 50% OF THE BUSINESS.
WE'D LOVE TO ACCEPT YOUR OFFER.
YOU'VE GOT A DEAL.
GREAT.
♪♪
I'M BRETT...
AND I'M HEATH,
AND WE'RE THE FOUNDERS
OF PORK BARREL BBQ.
PORK BARREL BBQ IS
A GOURMET SPICE RUB
AND BARBECUE SAUCE COMPANY.
SO MANY DOORS HAVE OPENED UP,
INCLUDING A BIG ONE TODAY.
HI, GUYS. WANNA TRY
A LITTLE BARBECUE CHICKEN?
(Heath) WE'RE HERE
TESTING OUR PRODUCTS,
AND THE PEOPLE AT COSTCO
ARE LOVING IT.
THE SAUCE IS DELICIOUS.
GETTING THE CHANCE TO BE
IN COSTCO IS WHAT
EVERY SMALL BUSINESS COULD HOPE
FOR. IT'S A REALLY HUGE DEAL.
YOU KNOW, MONTHS AGO
BEFORE OUR "SHARK TANK,"
WE HAD ONLY SOLD A FEW UNITS.
NOW WE'RE IN 130 GROCERY STORES.
WE HAVE A RESTAURANT. WE EVEN
HAVE OUR OWN CAMPAIGN BUS.
WE CALL IT "PORK BARREL ONE."
AND RECENTLY, WE HAD
A RIBBON CUTTING
FOR OUR NEW
PORK BARREL BBQ RESTAURANT
THAT'S COMING BECAUSE OF
THE DEAL WE GOT WITH BARBARA.
AND, I MEAN, IT'S
A TREMENDOUS OPPORTUNITY FOR US.
WE HAD THE MAYOR,
THE CITY COUNCIL,
OUR FAMILY AND FRIENDS.
LET'S EAT!
AND AT THE RIBBON CUTTING,
WE ALSO DID, UH,
ONE FINAL OBLIGATION, UH,
THAT I OWED BARBARA,
AND THAT WAS I WORE
A PIG COSTUME.
(man) YEAH! YEAH!
(cheering)
WHY, IN THE FIRST MONTH ALONE,
THESE GUYS HAVE SOLD
TO A MAJOR GROCERY STORE,
THEY'RE OPENING A BRAND‐NEW
RESTAURANT. I LOVE THESE GUYS!
(Brett) WE WERE SO THRILLED
WHEN BARBARA GAVE US A DEAL.
I MEAN, IT REALLY CHANGED THE‐‐
THE COURSE OF OUR COMPANY
AND OUR LIVES.
♪♪
I'M SANDY HYUN.
AND I'M ROMAN PIETRS.
WE LIVE IN NEW YORK CITY.
AND THE NAME OF OUR COMPANY
IS MR. PONCHO.
MR. PONCHO.
I'VE BEEN DESIGNING JEWELRY
FOR FIVE YEARS,
AND I CREATED MR. PONCHO
BECAUSE I NEEDED A SOLUTION
FOR AN EVERYDAY PROBLEM.
♪♪
I'M A GRAPHIC DESIGNER
AND MUSICIAN,
AND WHEN SANDY HAD THIS IDEA,
I FLIPPED OUT.
I THOUGHT TO MYSELF,
THIS IS PROBABLY HER
SECOND BEST IDEA SHE'S EVER HAD.
THE FIRST BEST, UH,
WAS HER DECISION TO DATE ME.
(laughs)
♪ WHAT YOU GONNA DO ♪
♪ WHEN YOUR CORDS
ARE ALL TANGLED UP?
♪ MR. PONCHO ♪
IT'S BEEN A GREAT EXPERIENCE
WORKING ON MR. PONCHO
WITH SANDY
IN OUR APARTMENT,
JUST THE TWO OF US.
(falsetto) ♪ MR. PONCHO... ♪
BUT WE JUST WANNA LIVE HERE.
WE DON'T WANNA WORK HERE.
(laughs) WHAT DO YOU THINK?
(grunts)
(laughs)
(Sandy) RIGHT NOW WE'RE MAKING
MONEY WITH MR. PONCHO.
AND HOPEFULLY THE SHARKS
WILL SEE THE POTENTIAL
THAT MR. PONCHO HAS
BECAUSE OF THAT.
(clicks tongue)
♪♪
HI, I'M SANDY HYUN.
AND MY NAME IS ROMAN PIETRS,
AND WE'RE HERE
FROM NEW YORK CITY.
AND THE NAME
OF OUR BUSINESS IS...
(both) ♪ MR. PONCHO ♪
♪ OH ♪
(sharks laugh)
UH, ROMAN, YOU CAN SING.
(Harrington) THAT'S FUNNY.
(Barbara) WOW.
THANK YOU.
WE'RE SEEKING
A $50,000 INVESTMENT,
AND WE'RE WILLING TO
PART WITH 25% EQUITY.
TO DATE, OVER 300 MILLION PEOPLE
HAVE PURCHASED MP3 PLAYERS
AND 200 MILLION SMARTPHONES.
THAT'S OVER 500 MILLION PAIRS
OF HEADPHONES
THAT ARE PROBABLY
GONNA END UP
LOOKING LIKE THIS TANGLED,
BROKEN MESS.
TANGLED HEADPHONES
ARE SO FRUSTRATING
FOR ANYBODY WHO USES
THESE PRODUCTS, INCLUDING US.
SO WHAT STARTED OUT
AS A SIMPLE SOLUTION
TO A VERY COMMON PROBLEM
LED TO OUR PRODUCT MR. PONCHO.
SO WITH MY JEWELRY DESIGN
BACKGROUND...
AND MY GRAPHIC DESIGN
BACKGROUND,
WE CREATED A PRODUCT WHICH
NOT ONLY SOLVES THE PROBLEM
OF TANGLED HEADPHONE CORDS,
BUT PROVIDES THE USER
WITH A FUN, FUNCTIONAL WAY
OF KEEPING THEIR MP3 PLAYER
OR SMARTPHONE SAFE.
HERE'S HOW IT WORKS.
YOU PUT YOUR MP3 PLAYER
IN THIS PROTECTIVE SLEEVE.
YOU POP THIS RUBBER PART OUT.
AND YOU SIMPLY WRAP AND UNWRAP
YOUR HEADPHONES JUST LIKE THAT.
IT'S SO EASY.
IT'S SO EASY AND SO FUN.
(chuckles)
SANDY, CAN I SEE ONE?
OH, SURE.
CAN WE ALL SEE ONE?
SO TELL ME ABOUT
THE SALES HISTORY.
(Roman) WE'VE BEEN IN BUSINESS
FOR TWO YEARS NOW.
OUR FIRST YEAR...
THANK YOU.
WE GROSSED, UH, $11,000.
AND OUR SECOND YEAR,
$35,000 IN GROSS PROFITS.
ROMAN, IT‐‐IT‐‐JUST SO I'M CLEAR
HOW IT WORKS, IT‐‐
DO YOU WANT ME TO‐‐
(Robert) THE CASE
IS ALL PART OF IT?
YEAH, YOU HAVE TO‐‐RIGHT,
AND YOU POP THIS RUBBER PART
OUT. YOU ACTUALLY FLIP IT OUT.
OH, I SEE. OKAY. OKAY.
IT'S REALLY DURABLE,
SO YOU COULD BE ROUGH WITH IT.
DO YOU HAVE A PATENT ON THIS?
THIS‐‐WE'VE GOT A PATENT PENDING
ON THE ENTIRE UNIT.
WE'VE‐‐WE'VE REPURPOSED THIS
LITTLE‐‐THIS LITTLE DEVICE.
RIGHT.
UH, WHICH‐‐WHICH HAS
ITS OWN PATENT. SO...
SO WHAT‐‐
A PATENT YOU HAVE?
ITS OWN PATENT?
NO, NO, NO. WE DON'T HAVE
A PATENT ON THIS...
(Barbara) THE CUP
THAT HOLDS THE WIRE.
THIS LITTLE‐‐
THIS LITTLE PIECE.
SO, ROMAN,
ONCE I POP IT OUT...
(Sandy) MM‐HMM.
I UNDO THIS.
YEP.
AND THEN
I LISTEN TO IT.
SURE.
GROOVE ALONG, AND THEN...
WHEN YOU'RE‐‐WHEN YOU WANT‐‐
DO I JUST FOLD IT BACK?
(Sandy) MM‐HMM.
YEAH, WHEN YOU WANNA‐‐
YOU MEAN THERE'S NO MECHANISM
WHERE IT AUTOMATICALLY REELS IN?
NO.
NO. I MEAN, THAT'S‐‐IT‐‐
IT'S‐‐
IT'S A REALLY, REALLY SIMPLE
LITTLE‐‐LITTLE DEVICE.
SO IT'S JUST A LITTLE‐‐HOW IS
THIS REALLY THAT MUCH DIFFERENT
THAN‐‐THAN ME TAKING
THE EARPHONES
AND WRAPPING THEM AROUND
MY iPhone?
WELL, I THINK YOU'RE GONNA FIND
THAT IF YOU DO THAT
AND YOU PUT THAT IN YOUR BAG,
SOMEHOW THOSE HEADPHONES
ARE GONNA MANAGE TO‐‐
I'D BUY THE PROTECTOR,
BUT YOU SAID
THAT THERE WAS A PATENT‐‐
BUT IT WASN'T YOURS‐‐
ON THIS PIECE.
SO THIS PIECE ACTUALLY HAS
A DIFFERENT PURPOSE.
SO WE REPURPOSED IT, ATTACHED IT
TO THEM UH, THE MP3 CASE.
(O'Leary) YEAH.
AND, UM, SO NOW IT'S A DIFFERENT
PRODUCT ALL TOGETHER.
WHAT'S IT SELL FOR?
IT SELLS FOR $18.
AND WE'VE SOLD OVER 5,000
OF THESE,
AND WE'VE MADE EVERY SINGLE ONE
OF THEM OURSELVES
IN OUR APARTMENT.
WHAT DOES IT COST YOU
TO MAKE IT?
IT COSTS $3
FOR US TO MAKE IT.
OKAY.
THAT DOESN'T PAY FOR YOUR OWN
LABOR. THAT'S FOR FREE, RIGHT?
THAT'S JUST MATERIALS?
YES. YES.
YEAH, EXACTLY.
AT THIS POINT IT'S FREE.
YEAH.
YOU GUYS ARE
MAKING THESE THINGS AT HOME.
YOU'RE SELLING THEM
FOR ABOUT $18.
HOW MUCH INFORMATION
DO YOU HAVE
ON WHAT IT WOULD COST
TO MANUFACTURE THIS PRODUCT?
BECAUSE IF YOU DO GET INTO
ONE OF THESE OUTLETS,
YOU WILL HAVE TO MAKE THOUSANDS
OR MILLIONS OF THESE.
DO YOU HAVE ANY INFORMATION
ON WHAT IT WOULD COST?
PROBABLY UNDER A DOLLAR.
BUT DO YOU KNOW THIS
FOR A FACT?
UH, JUST BUY THE COST
OF THE MATERIALS ALONE.
YOU, UH, YOU'VE PRICED THESE...
(Sandy) MM‐HMM.
WITH MANUFACTURERS?
OH, NO.
NOT WITH MANUFACTURERS.
ROMAN, MY KIDS
WOULDN'T BUY THIS.
AND THE REASON
THEY WOULDN'T BUY IT IS,
WHAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
TO THEM IS THE SKIN
THAT THEY PUT ON THEIR iPhone
OR ON THEIR BlackBerry.
I MEAN, KIDS LOVE THAT. THEY BUY
ONE TODAY BECAUSE GREEN IS COOL.
THEN THEY BUY PINK. AND THEY'RE
CHANGING THE COVER ALL THE TIME.
WHY COULDN'T YOU MAKE
THIS COMPONENT
THAT YOU COULD STICK ON
TO ANY SKIN?
SOMEONE ELSE HAS THE PATENT
ON WHAT THE CENTRAL DEVICE IS.
YOU KNOW, IT'S A SMALL BUSINESS.
YOU'RE OBVIOUSLY HAVING
SOME LEVEL OF SUCCESS.
IT'S INTERESTING. IT'S COOL.
AS AN INVESTOR, I'M OUT.
I LOVE THAT MIDDLE DEVICE‐‐
EXACTLY AS ROBERT WAS SAYING‐‐
WOULD BE A GREAT IDEA
IF YOU HAD THE PATENT.
I FEEL LIKE YOU DON'T HAVE
THE PATENT
ON THE REAL DEAL HERE,
SO I'M OUT.
♪♪
LOOK, I SAY DON'T QUIT
YOUR DAY JOBS.
(Barbara chuckles) GOSH.
NO, I CAN'T GIVE YOU $50,000.
I'M OUT.
THANK YOU.
SANDY, ROMAN, UH,
LIKE YOU GUYS.
THE BUSINESS, I THINK,
IS TOO PREMATURE.
YOU DON'T KNOW THE MANUFACTURING
ASPECT OF THIS,
SO I DON'T HAVE THOSE NUMBERS.
YOU DO NOT HAVE A PATENT
ON THIS PRODUCT.
THERE'S NO WINDOWS IN THERE TO
SEE WHAT MUSIC YOU'RE PLAYING.
I CAN'T SEE MYSELF ATTACHING IT
TO MY ARM OR MY BELT.
OH, NEVER THOUGHT OF THAT.
I THINK YOU'RE A LITTLE
TOO EARLY FOR ME TO GRASP IT.
I'M OUT.
(Harrington) I THINK YOU GOT
A GREAT HOME BUSINESS.
I THINK IT'S REALLY A, UH,
TO CONTINUE TO YOUR BUSINESS
AS YOUNG ENTREPRENEURS,
BUT AS AN INVESTOR, IT'S A TOUGH
THING FOR ME TO, UH, INVEST IN.
SO I'M OUT. THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE, THOUGH.
(both) THANK YOU.
♪♪
I FEEL LIKE THIS WHOLE PROCESS
SORT OF MADE ME
LOOK AT OUR BUSINESS
IN A DIFFERENT WAY.
MM‐HMM.
AND I THINK THAT'S
INFINITELY BENEFICIAL
TO THE FUTURE OF MR. PONCHO.
♪♪
MY NAME IS DR. FLOYD SESKIN,
AND I THINK
I'VE CREATED SOMETHING
THAT WILL HELP
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS.
I'VE BEEN A UROLOGIST
AND A SURGEON
FOR ALMOST 18 YEARS,
AND I DEVELOPED MY PRODUCT
BECAUSE OF THE FEEDBACK
I'VE GOTTEN
FROM MY VERY OWN PATIENTS.
HEY. HOW YOU DOING TODAY?
MANY OF MY PATIENTS STRUGGLE
WITH SLEEP
AND WORK AND OUTDOOR
RECREATIONAL ACTIVITIES.
AND I WANTED TO DEVELOP
SOMETHING THAT WOULD MAKE
THESE ACTIVITIES MUCH MORE
ENJOYABLE AND WORRY FREE.
I THINK THERE'S A GREAT NEED
FOR THIS PRODUCT,
BUT I DON'T HAVE THE EXPERTISE
TO DO THAT.
I'M A SURGEON.
THAT'S WHAT I DO FOR A LIVING,
AND THAT'S WHAT I DO BEST.
THE SHARKS HAVE THE CONNECTIONS.
THEY HAVE THE DISTRIBUTION
AND THE MANUFACTURING.
AND I'M LOOKING FOR THEM
TO TAKE THIS PROJECT
TO ITS MAXIMUM POTENTIAL.
♪♪
HELLO. MY NAME IS
DR. FLOYD SESKIN.
AND MY PRODUCT
IS THE UroClub.
I'M SEEKING A MERE $25,000
IN EXCHANGE FOR 51%
OF MY COMPANY.
I'M A BOARD CERTIFIED
UROLOGIST,
AND I HAVE A SUCCESSFUL PRACTICE
IN SOUTH FLORIDA.
MANY OF MY MALE PATIENTS
HAVE TWO THINGS IN COMMON.
NUMBER ONE...
WELL, THEY URINATE A LOT.
AND NUMBER TWO...
(Barbara and Robert laugh)
THEY LOVE TO PLAY GOLF.
(Robert) OH, NO.
AND IF YOU'VE BEEN
ON A GOLF COURSE,
I WON'T HAVE TO CONVINCE YOU
THAT TREES ARE SPARSE
AND THE BATHROOMS
ARE ALMOST NONEXISTENT.
THAT'S WHY MY PATIENTS
ENCOURAGED ME
TO DESIGN AND PRODUCE
THE UroClub.
I CAN'T WAIT TO SEE IT.
UH‐OH. I SEE
WHERE THIS IS GOING.
THIS IS A TRADEMARKED,
PATENT PENDING PRODUCT
THAT FUNCTIONS
AS A SELF‐CONTAINED RECEPTACLE.
(sharks laugh)
IT'S CLEVERLY CAMOUFLAGED
AS A GOLF CLUB.
(O'Leary) OH, YEAH!
(Robert laughs loudly)
IT'S INTENT IS TO ALLEVIATE
THE ANXIETY
AND THE EMBARRASSMENT
THAT MILLIONS OF MEN FEEL
WHEN THEY PLAY A ROUND OF GOLF.
(laughs)
IT LOOKS IDENTICAL
TO A 7‐IRON,
EXCEPT FOR THE WIDER GRIP
THAT FUNCTIONS AS THE RESERVOIR.
I DESIGNED THE CAP IN
CONJUNCTION WITH A PIPE FITTER
WHO ASSURED ME
THAT THIS WOULD NEVER LEAK.
IT ALSO COMES WITH A TOWEL
THAT I CALL THE PRIVACY SHIELD.
AND THIS EASILY FASTENS ONTO
THE FRONT OF THE UroClub...
(laughing)
AND CLIPS ON
TO YOUR WAISTBAND.
THIS ALLOWS THE TOWEL
TO DRAPE OVER YOU.
(Daymond) I'M SORRY?
CAN YOU GET STUCK?
WHAT?
NOBODY'S COMPLAINED YET,
BUT IT IS THE ONE SIZE FITS ALL
RIGHT NOW.
HOW IS BARBARA GONNA USE
THIS? SHE LOVES GOLFING.
HOW'S SHE GONNA USE
THIS DEVICE?
YOU KNOW, TO MAKE A‐A UroClub
FOR A WOMAN,
I'D HAVE TO MAKE A WHOLE
POP‐UP TENT WITH AN ATTENDANT,
I THINK,
TO TAKE YOU TO THE BATHROOM.
(laughs)
(Daymond) AND YOU WOULD NEED
SEVERAL OF 'EM, AND‐‐
THE GUY
TAKES OUT THE CLUB AND‐‐
AND SAYS, "EXCUSE ME,
KEVIN AND DAYMOND AND KEVIN..."
SURE.
"I HAVE TO GO USE MY CLUB"?
LISTEN, YOU'RE 125 YARDS
FROM THE GREEN,
AND YOU HAVE TO URINATE.
YOU TAKE OUT YOUR UroClub.
YOU RELIEVE YOURSELF.
YOU PUT YOUR UroClub AWAY.
RIGHT IN PUBLIC
WITHOUT BEING BEHIND A TREE?
I DON'T USE THE UroClub
TO MAKE THE SHOT.
NO, NO, NO.
IT IS NOT A FUNCTIONAL CLUB.
FLOYD, WELL,
WHEN I WAS ON THE GOLF COURSE,
I‐I NOTICED
THAT A LOT OF PEOPLE
ARE DRINKING
AN EXCESSIVE AMOUNT.
SO I THINK THAT THEY WOULD
TOP THAT THING OFF RIGHT AWAY,
AND YOU WOULD NEED
SEVERAL OF 'EM.
LET ME JUST TELL YOU THAT THE‐‐
THE CLUB HOLDS ABOUT 18 OUNCES,
WHICH, AS A UROLOGIST,
I CAN TELL YOU
IS MORE THAN THE AVERAGE PERSON
URINATES AT A GIVEN TIME.
REALLY?
THAT'S RIGHT.
IT JUST SEEMS SO SMALL.
IT'S NOT A PERFECT SOLUTION.
UH, IT'S NOT MADE TO, UH,
ELIMINATE BATHROOMS
AND THE NEED TO URINATE.
CAN I SEE IT?
ABSOLUTELY.
FLOYD, WHAT MADE YOU
THINK OF IT?
OBVIOUSLY YOU'RE A UROLOGIST.
BUT WHAT WAS IN YOUR HEAD
THE DAY YOU SAID...
(snaps fingers)
"HEY, I HAVE AN IDEA"?
THE REAL ANSWER TO THIS,
AND THIS IS THE TRUE STORY,
A PATIENT CAME BACK TO ME
SEVERAL MONTHS AFTER
AN OPERATION, AND HE TOLD ME
BECAUSE OF HIS URINARY
FREQUENCY, HE HAD TO CONSTANTLY
SLICE THE BALL INTO THE WOODS
TO RELIEVE HIMSELF.
AND HE SAID
AFTER THE PROCEDURE,
IT TOOK MORE STROKES OFF
HIS GAME THAN ANY CLUB HE BOUGHT
IN THE LAST FEW YEARS.
(Harrington) I'M A GOLFER.
I WOULD NEVER BUY THIS.
THIS IS A GAG GIFT, OKAY.
DON'T YOU SELL 'EM AS GAG GIFTS?
I THINK IT'S GOT
GREAT NOVELTY POTENTIAL.
OH.
I‐I‐I ALWAYS LOOK AT IT
THIS WAY.
ITS HUMOROUS, IT'S PRACTICAL,
AND IT'S WELL PRICED.
WHAT IS THE PRICE?
WHAT'S THE PRICE?
THE GOING PRICE RIGHT NOW
IS $24.95
PLUS, UH, $9.95
SHIPPING AND HANDLING.
WHAT'S IT COST YOU TO MAKE IT?
IT COST ME $8.43
TO‐‐TO MAKE IT.
(Robert) HOW MANY HAVE‐‐
HOW MANY HAVE YOU SOLD, FLOYD?
ABOUT 3,000.
(Barbara) I'M NOT TOUCHING
THE TOP. YOU CAN TOUCH IT.
WOW.
HANG ON A SEC.
YOU'VE SOLD 3,000?
YEAH.
H‐HOW?
WELL, I LIVE IN‐‐IN, UH,
IN SOUTH FLORIDA,
AND I‐I MADE
A‐AN INFOMERCIAL COMMERCIAL
THAT WAS ON
SOME LOCAL STATIONS.
WHAT WERE YOUR SALES?
UH, OVER $70,000...
WOW.
IN GROSS REVENUE.
THAT'S AMAZING.
YOU'RE DOING BUSINESS
ON THE WEB WITH THIS?
YES, I HAVE A WEB SITE,
AND THAT'S WHERE A LOT
OF MY BUSINESS HAS COME FROM,
THROUGH THE WEB.
HOW MUCH OF YOUR OWN MONEY
IS IN THIS?
UH, A LITTLE OVER $300,000.
WOW!
THAT IS A LOT OF MONEY.
HOW COULD YOU SPEND $300,000
ON A PEE PEE POLE?
HOW'S THAT POSSIBLE?
WELL, I HAD 15,000
INITIALLY IN STOCK.
THIS IS TRADEMARKED, AND IT'S,
UH, THE PATENT IS PENDING.
AND I THINK YOU GUYS KNOW
WHAT‐‐WHAT THAT CAN RUN.
YEAH.
HOW MUCH INVENTORY DO YOU HAVE?
RIGHT NOW I HAVE 12,000 UNITS.
FLOYD, IF YOU STAND
IN THE MIDDLE OF A FAIRWAY...
MM‐HMM.
EVEN WITH THE, UH,
GREEN TOWEL,
AND YOU AERATE YOUR PACKAGE...
(laughs)
IS THAT NOT INDECENT EXPOSURE
IN SOME COUNTIES?
I DON'T THINK IT IS.
BUT I THINK THAT
WHEN YOU'RE ON A GOLF COURSE,
IT'S GOING TO HAPPEN.
SO IT'S GONNA HAPPEN
EITHER IN THE WOODS
OR IT'S GONNA HAPPEN
A LITTLE BIT MORE CONCEALED.
FLOYD, UM,
THE HIDDEN THING HERE
IS THAT THE FACT THAT YOU'RE
ASKING FOR $25,000 FOR 51%.
YOU'RE A‐‐YOU'RE A DOCTOR.
YOU DON'T NEED THE MONEY.
YOU'RE LOOKING FOR A STRATEGIC
RELATIONSHIP OBVIOUSLY.
EXACTLY.
AND, UM, I WOULDN'T KNOW
HOW TO MARKET THAT.
I DO LIKE TO CALL MYSELF
"THE BRAND WHISPERER,"
BUT I WOULDN'T KNOW
HOW TO MARKET THAT.
SO WITH THAT SAID,
I'M OUT.
OKAY.
AND IF YOU THINK, UH, HE DOESN'T
KNOW HOW TO MARKET IT...
(laughs)
I‐I OBVIOUSLY CAN'T RELATE
TO THIS PARTICULAR PRODUCT,
SO I'M OUT.
I‐I CANNOT SEE ME... (chuckles)
UM, UTILIZING THAT DEVICE
UNDER ANY SITUATION.
I CAN'T INVEST IN SOMETHING
I WOULD NEVER USE. I'M OUT.
IT'S A VERY INTRIGUING
PRODUCT.
AND, UM, YOU KNOW,
BUT AS AN INVESTMENT,
I JUST DON'T SEE IT
FITTING INTO MY PORTFOLIO,
TO BE HONEST WITH YOU.
DO YOU SEE YOUR PORTFOLIO
FITTING INTO THE INVESTMENT?
I THINK MY PORTFOLIO MAY HAVE
A PROBLEM GETTING INSIDE THAT.
(laughs)
ANYWAYS, UH, FLOYD, I'M OUT.
I LOOK AT IT AS A PRODUCT
THAT DOES HAVE SOME POTENTIAL,
AS‐‐AS A NOVELTY,
GAG‐TYPE PRODUCT.
AND, UH, THERE'S A LOT
OF GOLF WEB SITES OUT THERE.
THERE'S‐‐AT CHRISTMASTIME,
EVERYONE'S LOOKING FOR,
YOU KNOW, SOMETHING TO BUY
FOR THAT‐‐THAT SPECIAL GOLFER.
THIS IS THE DEAL
THAT I WOULD MAKE YOU.
YOU'VE GOT A TV COMMERCIAL.
YOU'VE GOT INVENTORY.
I WOULD GIVE YOU THE $25,000
FOR 70% OF THE COMPANY.
YOU'RE GONNA BUY
THE PEE PEE POLE? WOW.
SO IT'S 70%?
FOR $25,000.
I LOVE IT.
OKAY. (claps hands)
SUPER, RIGHT? ALL RIGHTY.
(O'Leary) CONGRATULATIONS.
NOT IN A MILLION YEARS...
(Daymond) CONGRATULATIONS.
DID I THINK THE PEE PEE POLE
WOULD GET A DEAL.
(Barbara laughs)
(O'Leary) OKAY, NOW BOTH OF YOU
WASH YOUR HANDS.
(sharks laugh)
I WAS HAPPY WITH THE DEAL.
I WAS ACTUALLY WILLING TO TAKE
EVEN LESS BECAUSE I KNOW
THAT KEVIN CAN MAKE THIS PRODUCT
A HUGE SUCCESS.
♪♪
NEXT UP ARE BRIAN DUGGAN
AND ADAM McCOMBS
WITH AN INNOVATIVE NEW BUSINESS
SET TO CHANGE THE FACE
OF COLLEGE SPORTS RECRUITING.
♪♪
HELLO, MY NAME
IS BRIAN DUGGAN.
AND I'M‐‐AND I'M ADAM McCOMBS,
AND WE'RE FROM JumpForward.
WE'RE OFFERING 10%
OF OUR COMPANY
IN EXCHANGE
FOR ONLY $150,000.
DWYANE WADE, THE NBA CHAMPION
OF THE MIAMI HEAT,
JERRY RICE, THE GREATEST
NFL WIDE RECEIVER OF ALL TIMES,
AND NBA STAR BEN WALLACE‐‐
WHAT DO THESE ATHLETES
ALL HAVE IN COMMON?
THEY WERE ALL OVERLOOKED
DURING THE HIGH SCHOOL
ATHLETIC RECRUITING PROCESS.
THERE ARE THOUSANDS OF
HIGH SCHOOL ATHLETES EACH YEAR
WHO NEVER ATTRACT THE ATTENTION
OF COLLEGE COACHES
AND ARE OVERLOOKED.
JumpForward EMPOWERS
HIGH SCHOOL ATHLETES AND PARENTS
TO TAKE CONTROL OF THE ROUT‐‐
THE RECRUITING PROCESS
INTO THEIR OWN HANDS.
WE DO THIS BY PROVIDING THEM
AN ONLINE PROFILE
THAT ENABLES THEM TO UPLOAD
PICTURES, VIDEOS AND STATISTICS
TO MARKET THEMSELVES
TO COLLEGES.
AT THE SAME TIME,
COLLEGE COACHES CAN NOW SEARCH
THROUGH TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF ATHLETIC PROFILES
TO FIND THOSE ATHLETES MOST
APPROPRIATE FOR THEIR PROGRAM.
COLLEGE COACHES ARE UNDER STRICT
GUIDELINES FROM THE N. C. A. A.
WITH REGARD TO COMMUNICATION
WITH HIGH SCHOOL ATHLETES.
FOR EXAMPLE, COACHES ARE
ONLY ABLE TO MAKE ONE CALL
TO CERTAIN HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENT PROSPECT ATHLETES.
HOWEVER, COMPLIANCE VIOLATIONS
FOR INFRACTIONS ARE HUGE.
I GET IT.
HOW DO I MAKE MONEY?
CURRENTLY, THE COLLEGES PAY
A SUBSCRIPTION FEE.
WE CHARGE BASED ON
THE LEVEL OF SCHOOL.
THAT'S AN ANNUAL SUBSCRIPTION,
PLUS WE CHARGE FEES FOR
MAINTENANCE AND, UH, CONSULTING.
HAVE YOU SOLD
ANY MAJOR SCHOOLS?
WE HAVE TO DATE OVER
30 DIFFERENT SCHOOLS SIGNED UP,
300 COLLEGE COACHES
IN THE SYSTEM,
60,000 PROSPECTIVE
STUDENT ATHLETES IN THE SYSTEM.
TO GET DOWN TO MONEY,
IN THREE MONTHS ALONE,
WE'VE GENERATED $150,000
IN CONTRACTS.
I VIEW THIS BUSINESS,
WITH OUR POTENTIAL,
TO MAX OUT AT ABOUT
$15 OR $20 MILLION.
WITH YOUR EXPERTISE,
I BELIEVE WE CAN TAKE THIS
TO A $35‐MILLION,
TOP‐LINE REVENUE BUSINESS.
WHAT'S THE COMPETITION LIKE
RIGHT NOW?
THERE ARE A NUMBER
OF SMALLER COMPETITORS.
I'LL TELL YOU THIS.
WHAT DIFFERENTIATES US
FROM ALL OF THE COMPETITION
IS THAT WE PROACTIVELY
PREVENT VIOLATIONS.
WE'RE THE ONLY SOLUTION
IN THE MARKET THAT DOES THAT.
COACHES OPERATE
FROM THE MOBILE PHONE.
THE RULES AND REGULATIONS
ARE COMPLEX.
AND WITH THE PROLIFERATION
OF COMMUNICATION OPTIONS‐‐
JUST IN
THE LAST TWO YEARS ALONE‐‐
COACHES WENT FROM JUST USING
THE PHONE AND SNAIL MAIL
TO TEXT MESSAGING, Facebook
AND TWITTER.
ALL OF THOSE RULES
AND REGULATIONS
ARE ON OUR PROPRIETARY‐‐
AND YOU'RE SAYING
THAT NONE OF YOUR COMPETITORS
CAN INCORPORATE
THAT FUNCTIONALITY?
NOBODY HAS IT TODAY.
WE HAVE A PATENT
ON THE MOBILE APPLICATION.
SO I PUT YOUR CLIENT
ON THE COACH'S BlackBerry.
AND IF HE TEXTS OR E‐MAILS
OR CALLS THE SAME GREAT ATHLETE,
AUTOMATICALLY, WHAT, A SCREEN
POPS UP AND SAYS "STOP"?
YEAH. THERE'S CONFIRMATION
SO WE KNOW THAT, UM,
THEY SAW THE MESSAGE.
IF THEY GO AHEAD AND OVERRIDE
IT, THEY'VE SEEN THE MESSAGE
AND THEY'VE MADE THE CONSCIOUS
DECISION TO OVERRIDE IT.
(Barbara) YOU'RE OBVIOUSLY
VERY SMART GUYS.
YOU'VE THOUGHT THIS PRESENTATION
THROUGH. HERE'S WHAT I MISTRUST.
I HAVE BUILT
TECHNOLOGY BUSINESSES.
THEY'RE ALWAYS
TWICE AND THREE TIMES MORE
THAN YOU EVER ENVISION.
I'VE NEVER SEEN
A TECHNOLOGY BUSINESS
NOT SPEND SO MUCH MORE
THAN THEY DICTATED.
SO FOR THAT,
I'M DEFINITELY OUT
'CAUSE I DON'T EVER WANT
TO MAKE THAT MISTAKE AGAIN.
THIS IS HIGH‐TECH.
IT'S VERY RISKY.
I'D BE AFRAID IF I PUT $150,000
INTO THIS COMPANY,
THAT COULD BE GONE
IN THREE MONTHS.
SO, UH, I'M OUT.
BRIAN, ADAM,
UM, YOU GUYS ARE WAY TOO SMART
FOR ME.
IT'S A LITTLE COMPLICATED.
I'M OUT.
THREE SHARKS ARE OUT.
ROBERT AND KEVIN O'LEARY
ARE THEIR LAST CHANCE.
BRIAN, DO YOU THINK YOUR VALUE
IS IN THE PATENT
OR DO YOU THINK YOUR VALUE
IS GOING OUT TO MARKET
AND GETTING CUSTOMERS?
FIRST, I THINK WE HAVE
A STRONG, COMPETITIVE ADVANTAGE
BY BEING A FIRST MOVER
IN THE SPACE.
TWO, I THINK WE HAVE
A COMPETITIVE ADVANTAGE
IN HAVING A PATENT
ON THE MOBILE APPLICATION.
AND THREE, I THINK WE HAVE
A COMPETITIVE ADVANTAGE
IN THE MANAGEMENT TEAM
THAT YOU SEE BEFORE YOU,
BECAUSE WE'RE BOTH EXPERTS
IN OUR RESPECTIVE FIELDS.
BRIAN, WHAT'S YOUR BACKGROUND?
I WAS AT ERNST & YOUNG,
DID ACCOUNTING
AND COMPLIANCE AUDIT FOR THEM.
I THEN WENT ON
TO DO INVESTMENT BANKING, UH,
MERGERS AND ACQUISITIONS,
CAPITAL MARKETS.
(Robert) WHAT ABOUT ADAM?
I DID ERNST & YOUNG,
INTERNAL AUDITOR.
BUT THEN I SPENT EIGHT YEARS
AT CISCO SYSTEMS.
I HAVE, UH, TWO C. C. I. E. s,
WHICH ARE ESSENTIALLY
TWO PhDs IN THE INTERNET.
(O'Leary) WOW. VERY IMPRESSIVE.
(Brian) THANK YOU.
BRIAN, LISTEN. I LIKE THE STORY.
I LIKE YOU GUYS.
I LIKE THIS MARKET.
I'LL MAKE YOU AN OFFER.
I'LL GIVE YOU $200,000 FOR 20%.
WE'LL TAKE
THAT UNDER CONSIDERATION.
$300,000 FOR 35%.
ROBERT...
I THINK YOU NEED‐‐
I THINK YOU NEED MORE CASH.
YOU KNOW, ROBERT,
THERE'S A‐‐
(man speaks indistinctly)
EXCUSE ME, GUYS.
WHY DON'T YOU TURN AROUND
AND JUST EXIT
FOR A COUPLE MINUTES?
I HAVE TO DISCUSS SOMETHING
WITH, UM, WITH ROBERT OVER HERE.
THANK YOU.
LET ME TELL YOU SOMETHING‐‐
WE DON'T WANT TO DO
WHAT WE'RE ABOUT TO DO
TO EACH OTHER.
THIS IS GONNA GET
REALLY EXPENSIVE,
SO LET'S STOP RIGHT NOW.
THINK ABOUT IT.
I‐‐
IT'S A BIG MISTAKE
TO (bleep) ME ON THIS ONE.
ARE YOU‐‐
ARE YOU THREATENING ME?
ARE YOU SAYING
YOU'RE GONNA GO UP?
NO, I'M JUST SAYING THERE'S
TWO WAYS THIS COULD GO‐‐
WE CAN STOP RAISING THE PRICE
AND COLLUDE WITH EACH OTHER
TO OUR ADVANTAGE, GIVE THEM
LESS CASH FOR MORE EQUITY‐‐
WHICH IS REALLY WHAT'S ABOUT
TO HAPPEN IF YOU'RE SMART‐‐
OR WE CAN COMPETE.
I THINK THEY'RE GONNA GO
WITH MY $300,000 FOR 35%.
WHY NOT GO $400,000 FOR 50%?
OOH, I LIKE THAT.
I LIKE 50%.
50/50. AND WE‐‐
OH, THAT'S INTERESTING TO ME.
THAT'S VERY INTERESTING.
LET'S BRING 'EM BACK. BRIAN?
TWO OF US HAVE BEEN WHERE YOU
GUYS ARE BEFORE,
NOT JUST ONCE, MULTIPLE TIMES.
AND WE KNOW WHAT IT TAKES TO BE
SUCCESSFUL, AND THAT'S MONEY.
WHATEVER YOU THINK YOU'RE GONNA
NEED, YOU'RE GONNA NEED MORE.
THE KEY TODAY IS TO HAVE
A BUFFER OF CASH.
SO THE GOOD NEWS
IS YOU CAME IN
LOOKING FOR $150,000.
WE'RE GONNA OFFER YOU
$400,000.
AND THERE'S MORE GOOD NEWS.
IT'S ONLY GOING TO BE 50%.
I APPRECIATE THE OFFER,
BUT WHAT I'LL ASK YOU TO DO
IS BACK OFF THE‐‐THE 50%,
SO THAT WE HAVE MORE ROOM
TO MANAGE THE BUSINESS,
TO ALLOCATE EQUITY
TO NEW AND FUTURE EMPLOYEES
AND GO BACK
TO THE $200,000 OFFER.
WOW. YOU GUYS ARE SAYING NO
TO THE EXTRA CASH?
YES, SIR, WE ARE.
I LOVE YOU EVEN MORE.
BRIAN, ADAM, I'M SPEECHLESS.
I TOLD YOU THEY‐‐THEY WERE
SMARTER THAN ME,
'CAUSE I'D HAVE GRABBED
THAT CASH AND RAN ALREADY.
SO, BRIAN, WE OFFERED YOU
$400,000 FOR 50%,
AND YOU'VE COUNTERED WITH...
I'D LIKE TO GO BACK
TO THE $200,000 THAT YOU
INITIALLY OFFERED, BUT I DIDN'T
STATE AN EQUITY AMOUNT.
WHAT ARE YOU OFFERING ME?
$200,000 FOR WHAT PERCENTAGE?
WELL, LET'S PULL OUT
A CALCULATOR AND FIND OUT,
SO THAT WE DON'T...
HE GOT A CALCULATOR.
HE GOT A CALCULATOR ON HIM.
YOU KNOW IT'S NEVER GOOD WHEN
YOU NEED A CALCULATOR, BRIAN.
(Brian) NO, SIR.
16% OF THE BUSINESS.
NO. TOO LOW. IT DOESN'T HAVE
THE GOOD FEELING TO IT.
WHAT IT DOES IS, IT POSITIONS
YOU WITH THE MANAGEMENT TEAM
IN A BUSINESS MODEL
THAT IS PROVEN.
I STILL LIKE
THE $400,000 FOR 50%.
I THINK YOU'RE GONNA NEED
MORE CASH.
I DON'T BELIEVE THAT WE WILL BE
UNABLE TO RAISE CAPITAL
IN 60 OR 90 DAYS.
I BELIEVE THAT
WE HAVE A GOOD STORY, AND IF I‐‐
$500,000 FOR 50%.
AGAIN, I APPRECIATE THE OFFER‐‐
WAIT A SECOND.
BEFORE YOU SAY NO TO THAT, THINK
ABOUT THAT. THINK ABOUT THAT.
THIS ISN'T "MONOPOLY" MONEY.
YOU REALIZE THAT, BRIAN?
IT'S‐‐IT'S PRETTY HARD
TO GET CASH.
ROBERT, I REAL‐‐
I APPRECIATE YOUR OFFER,
BECAUSE WE HAVE $300,000
OF OUR OWN MONEY IN IT.
YOU KNOW, WE DON'T TAKE
THE DECISION LIGHTLY.
$600,000 FOR 50%.
I...
♪♪
ROBERT AND KEVIN
HAVE OFFERED $600,000‐‐
A STAGGERING $450,000 OVER
THE ORIGINAL ASKING AMOUNT‐‐
BUT THEY WANT 50%
OF THE COMPANY.
YOU'VE GOTTEN, UH,
AN OFFER FOR MORE MONEY THAN
YOU CAME LOOKING FOR.
$600,000 FOR 50%.
I MEAN, IT ALMOST HURTS ME
TO SAY THAT.
AND YOUR ANSWER TO THAT
IS WHAT?
WHAT I'M GOING TO SUGGEST
IS ONE OF TWO OPTIONS.
IF YOUR GOAL IS TO HAVE 50%
OF THIS BUSINESS,
WE'RE PREPARED TO DO THAT,
PROVIDED TWO THINGS‐‐
ONE, YOU'RE BOTH IN,
AND TWO, IT'S AT $750,000.
WHAT'S THE OTHER OPTION?
THE OTHER OPTION IS
WE TAKE $300,000,
RIGHT,
INSTEAD OF YOUR $600,000...
FOR WHAT PERCENTAGE?
FOR‐‐YOU'RE CATCHING ME.
DO I WANT TO PULL
MY CALCULATOR OUT OR NOT?
YES, YOU DO.
BECAUSE THE ONLY WAY YOU CAN
EXPLAIN THIS IS
TO KEEP IT
VERY, VERY SIMPLE.
25%.
JUST RECAP THE OFFERS FOR ME.
OFFER NUMBER ONE‐‐$300,000
FOR 25% OF THE BUSINESS.
OFFER NUMBER TWO?
$750,000
FOR 50% OF THE BUSINESS.
I THINK YOU NEED MY MONEY.
I'M GONNA STICK
TO THE $600,000 FOR 50%.
I'M GONNA STAY WITH HIM THERE,
AND I THINK YOU GUYS ARE INSANE
TO WALK OUT WITHOUT THAT MONEY.
SO YOUR FINAL OFFER
IS $600,000 FOR 50%?
YOU WOULD NOT ENTERTAIN
A LOWER DOLLAR NUMBER
AT THE EXACT SAME VALUATION?
I WANT 50%.
$750,000 BUYS YOU 50%.
I RESPECT WHAT YOU'RE SAYING,
BUT EVERYTHING HAS A PRICE,
AND I THINK YOU'VE EXCEEDED
WHAT I'M WILLING TO PAY
FOR 50%.
THERE'S A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT
OF EXPERIENCE AND HISTORY
AND TALENT HERE.
AND I DON'T THINK YOU'RE
PUTTING ENOUGH VALUE ON THAT
ALONG WITH
THE $600,000 OF CASH.
BRIAN, I'VE BUILT
FOUR COMPANIES FROM ZERO
TO $50‐TO‐$100 MILLION
IN LESS THAN 5 YEARS.
DONE.
OH.
GOOD DEAL, GUYS. I LIKE IT.
I THINK WE CAN MAKE SOME MONEY.
I DO, TOO.
THANK YOU, ROBERT.
BRIAN, YOU HAD
A VERY GOOD PRESENTATION.
KEVIN, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
APPRECIATE IT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ALL.
SEE YOU GUYS. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME. APPRECIATE IT.
♪♪
WHAT DID YOU LEARN
FROM ME THERE?
UM, I LIKE‐‐
STICK TO YOUR GUNS.
I LIKE MORE.
MORE IS BETTER.
YEAH. THAT WAS GOOD.
WE WENT IN ASKING FOR $150,000.
WE CAME OUT WITH $600,000.
I'D SAY WE DID PRETTY GOOD.
I WOULD SAY WE DID VERY GOOD.